some alien life force has sent real-life
video games to attack us
bad here's my impression of everyone
that watched that trailer oh oh oh okay
oh yeah how Adam Sandler stop let's talk
about how we all just caught blue-balled
this is hashtag news
the trailer for pixel's has arrived set
to come out that summer pixel is about
classic 80s video games that are brought
to life by an alien race to attack earth
this movie has everything obligatory
shots of famous landmarks being
destroyed
product placement cars no one's driven
since the Italian Job tyrion lanister
quoting the kool-aid guy but before you
feed this one your token pixels has a
glitch and I don't mean an adorable
twitch like vanellope from wreck-it
Ralph oh here it is aka my spirit animal
I mean a bummer glitch in the form of a
certain leading male who's not aging
nearly as well as his video game
co-stars
good warned oh no no not him think it's
a sexy sensei I'm talking about him we
are all gonna die
Sandler our once hero from the hilarious
wedding singer Billy Madison and happy
gilmore who betrayed us with the --until
arias grown-ups Jack and Jill blended
grownups too
you don't mess with the Zohan getting ad
paul blart to the mix and suddenly the
most epic 80s throwback movie has turned
to chuck and Larry trying to destroy my
childhood seriously
Adam Sandler he's like the guy who tries
to be the class clown but instead annoys
everyone chlorophyll more like boring
fail right I'm just sorry you know maybe
we've all been a little too hard on Adam
Sandler after all he was a big star in
the nineties and he made us laugh
recently on SNL and the night of too
many stars he gives a lot to charity and
by charity I mean Rob Schneider's entire
career you can do it you can't do it oh
listen video game characters coming to
life and having to battle them
definitely gets me going
daki calm at least he got Donkey Kong's
name right dankey kahng that lady is
stupid it's a stupid woman who knows
pixels could be the most intense
showdown between man and video games
since wargames try or that time I was on
an early 90s Nickelodeon game show Nick
arcade though my episode never aired
because of what happened to me in the
jungle level okay and three of the Treen
get those stupid bananas ie bullet bunny
monkey al token and you pieces monkey oh
no not another bird fish fighting me
nice my gosh I might have just been
green screen but I was in intensive care
for weeks at least my spinal injury got
that show swiftly canceled anyway like
this video and let me know in the
comments if you're actually gonna go see
this movie can you stand Adam Sandler
and what what are these right here
Oh click thumbs right there and become
one of our subscribers guys because we
like you I'm gonna use spare with her
and I'm just a glitch in your computer
let me out let me out